bonjour et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur rt france qu'est les
profils de ces manifestants qui
protestent depuis maintenant plusieurs
jours à barcelone
c'est un profil bas voire c'est un
profil qui est un mélange de plusieurs
sortes de collectifs de des gens qui se
mobilisent à la base à des anarchistes
mais après ils ont retrouvé du soutien
d'autres groupes qui ont fait comme
certaines des personnes qui ont pré qui
ont exprimé leurs paroles avant c'est la
goutte qui a fait déborder le vase et
qui a fait que il mélange des différents
collectifs sur ces manifestations c'est
mobilisent à barcelone a majoritairement
ces dernières semaines et ça c'est pour
les manifestations de la journée mais le
soir comment est-ce que vous expliquer
ces affrontements qui se répète entre
protestataires et forces de l'ordre
les blancs et les manifestations
commencent vers le soir se déroule en
premiers instants en comme toutes les
manifestations c'est une droite à qui
est basique qui est dans une société
démocratique fait partie des droits
fondamentaux le droit de pouvoir se
manifester c'est aussi évident que ao de
roulement au fur et à mesure de ces
manifestations
c'est déroulement à des collectifs très
violent a tout à coup tourner leurs
activités envers la police et comment
cette activité très violente envers les
lignes policiers auxquels nous on doit y
faire face
parce que c'est complètement
intolérables alors une jeune fille a
perdu en est probablement après un tir
de balle en caoutchouc probablement de
la police la tension et beaucoup porter
ces derniers jours sur l'action
justement de la police catalane qu'est
ce que ça vous inspire
en fait la police sépare le problème la
police et la solution du problème en
tout cas et si jamais il ya une
sensation de fatigue généralisée en
catalogne à cause de la bande d'amis à
cause de plans d'autres problèmes qui
qui viennent avec la crise
j'en suis sûr que la police ne l'a pas
responsable de cette fatigue généralisée
et ce sont les institutions qui vont
devoir y faire face à la police en tout
cas est ce la dernière échelle c'est
l'échelle qui doit faire face
on déjà en droit public et on a
l'obligation de rétablir l'ordre et la
sécurité à la ville ça c'est notre
devoir et ce rapport sur un pur catalan
tableau excel a été condamné à neuf mois
de prison après des tweets contre la
police et la monarchie
considéré par la justice comme une
apologie du terrorisme est ce que vous
diriez qu'il ya aujourd'hui en effet
tableau à celle sur la perception de la
police dont l'opinion chat ça
m'appartient à moi ça m'appartient pas à
moi de dire cette cet effet sur la
police est en tout cas si cette
condamnation elle est juste ou pas juste
en fait la police travaille pour
garantir la sécurité en ville en
catalogne en dans toutes les villes et
pour garantir la sécurité de tous les
citoyens et de tous les immeubles a
éventuellement les faits pablo à celle
ça a été effectivement la goutte qui a
débordé le vase
mais on doit chercher l'explication de
7,1 à sensation transversale de
malheureuses les gens sont malheureux
les gens sont fatigués les gens sont au
bout de leur patience à à ça c'est tout
à fait compréhensible
moi je critique pas ça ce qui est
intolérable c'est la violence qu'on voit
dans les rues à barcelone principalement
et surtout la violence qui est un qui
est exercée envers la police en ça sert
tout à fait intolérable parce que eux
ils sont le 40 dans un état démocratique
tous sont artistes dont le cinéaste
pedro almodovar et l'acteur javier
bardem ont signé une pétition pour la
défense du rappeur et contre son
incarcération elle cette affaire vous
dites vous même dépasser cette affaire
dépasse la classe politique comment
est-ce que selon vous on peut la
résoudre pacifiquement également sur le
terrain pour le travail de la police
il faut que les politiciens
réfléchissent et trouvent des accords
ans parce que si ça c'est la raison de
cette sensation de fatigue
il faut que tous les partis politiques
et au corps gras il me semble qu'il ya
déjà plusieurs forces politiques qui se
sont prononcés c'est pas à moi en tant
que responsable de la sécurité de faire
de considération à par rapport à 6 c'est
juste que c'est pas juste en a moins
cher en tout cas jean place jeu il faut
que le congrès espagnol la façon
réflexion à pacific bien réfléchi de
quelles sont les limites des droits
d'expression
et s'il faut que ce soit a revu je suis
sûr que nous en tant que garant de la
sécurité
on va y travailler mais j'insiste chose
de celle la liberté d'expression et tous
à sa compagne avec une réflexion qui
doit être faite au centre du congrès et
autres choses soient bien différente
c'est accepter et tolérer la violence
qu'on est en train de voir un ces jours
ci à dans les rues de barcelone
majoritairement merci beaucoup d'avoir
pris le temps de réagir sur notre
antenne père et ferrer un ca serai je
rappelle que vous êtes directeur de la
police catalane